want to know what's heating up in  theaters this weekend the place where  Memphis science me monster sticks is a  team of explorers land on an uncharted  island inhabited by monsters in Kong  skyline  whoever died first was on the other side  here in personal shopper Kristen Stewart  believe she can contact the dead but is  it all just really her imagination I  love I can't tell whether or not I'm  going crazy a vegan forced to eat raw  meat during a college hazing ritual  discovers she has an appetite for flesh  in more ways than one  in raw see what's hot in theaters with  this week's anticipation  [Music]  so what's your weekend to get going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]